Die zwei Sprechstunden. Ich bin ein Hackergedankens, Störende und Chaos Computer Club Berlin.
Hallo.
So, habe ich jetzt den Namen richtig gesagt? Freifunk, Freifunk, Freedom Fighters. Wie heißt es?
Ja, also ohne Lachen heißt es Freifunk Freedom Fighter Box.
Okay, so, könnt ihr dreimal hintereinander sagen, wer es zum Freistift kriegt einen Gummipunkt. Was genau ist das und was wollt ihr damit erreichen?
Die Freifunk Freedom Fighter Box ist erstmal ein Access Point, also ein WLAN Router, der mit einem offenen Betriebssystem läuft, das heißt OpenWRT, und der den Datenverkehr, der jetzt aus dem öffentlichen WLAN oder aus dem unverschlüsselten öffentlichen WLAN kommt, über einen sogenannten VPN-Tunnel zu einem Provider nach Schweden schickt. Der Provider hat uns für diese Kampagne 100 VPN-Tunnel-Endpunkte gespendet. Und das heißt also, der öffentliche WLAN-Verkehr purzelt jetzt nicht mehr bei einem deutschen Provider ins Internet. Ihr habt ja vorhin schon erklärt, was dann passieren könnte, sondern eben über diesen Provider in Schweden. Und damit ist sowohl der Anschlussinhaber, also der DSL-Inhaber, als auch die Personen, natürlich die über WLAN surften, bleiben anonym. Und die Störerhaftung greift nicht oder kann da gar nicht greifen.
Also anonym bleibt es insofern, dass dann nur der Typ in Schweden weiß, wer da gerade surft.
Das weiß er ja auch nicht. Er könnte eventuell wissen, wer der Anschlussinhaber ist, und es wird ihn aber nicht.
Okay. Das heißt also, wenn jetzt jemand da abmahnen will, dann kriegt er diese IP-Adresse, die in Schweden irgendwo ist, und da kriegt er nichts gesagt. Ihr habt das jetzt irgendwie eingerichtet, so ein Ding. Ihr habt diesen VPN-Tunnel geschenkt bekommen. Wie teuer wäre denn sowas, wenn man sich das selber einrichtet?
Also solche Angebote gibt es überall im Internet. Der Preis ist ungefähr 5 Euro im Monat für so einen VPN-Tunnel-Endpunkt.
Hat das irgendwelche Nachteile, so einen VPN zu benutzen?
Na ja, zum einen kostet es Geld zusätzlich zu meinem Internetanschluss, den ich ja sowieso schon habe. Und zum anderen habe ich in der Regel auch nicht die Bandbreite, die mein Internetzugang eben theoretisch bieten würde.
Also ist das ein bisschen schmaler, weil es nochmal ein extra Weg ist?
Ja, oder auch weil der Provider eben die Bandbreite innen über diesen Tunnel von sich aus einschränkt.
Achso, also mein Internetprovider kann erkennen, dass ich so einen VPN-Tunnel benutze und sagt dann...
Achso, nee, nee, nicht deiner, sondern der VPN-Betreiber.
Der sagt so, hier, du kannst bei mir schon anonym surfen, dann muss es nicht auch noch breitbandig sein.
Genau.
Okay, das heißt also, es ist eine technische Lösung für dieses Problem. Wie gut ist die angenommen worden? Also ich habe so eine Teile ja verschenkt, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe.
Ja, ich bin jetzt auch unter anderem in den letzten Tagen durch verschiedene Cafés gezogen und habe mit den Eigentümern dieser Läden gesprochen. Ich war wahnsinnig überrascht und schockiert, wie viele Abmahnungen die schon erhalten haben. Und es ist bei einigen sogar so weit, dass die dann ihr Internet abgeschaltet haben. Und naja, wenn man erst mal erklärt hat, dass es tatsächlich legal ist, ein ganz wichtiger Punkt und dass man halt auch in Deutschland nach wie vor anonym ins Internet darf, und dann vielleicht auch noch auf die Medienberichte, die es jetzt eben schon gegeben hat, verweist, dann ist die Bereitschaft sehr groß, das Angebot auch anzunehmen.
Das ist aber tatsächlich die erste Angst, also dass sozusagen, wir haben hier eine Box, die lässt sich anonym surfen. Ist denn das überhaupt erlaubt?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich so die öffentliche Meinung mittlerweile so weit degradiert, dass schon viele Leute so ein Gefühl haben, so anonym ins Internet, das kann doch gar nicht legal sein. Ich habe auch gleich noch mal eine Frage an euch, vielleicht passt das gerade noch nicht, aber vielleicht, dass wir es noch mal diskutieren. Es ging immer um Hochladen oder Runterladen von Musik. Meiner Meinung nach ist nur das Hochladen wirklich ein Problem, aber da können wir nachher auch noch mal drüber reden.
Oh, okay, das ist ja, glaube ich, eine andere Diskussion, kann man vielleicht noch mal kurz anschauen nachher. Ich würde jetzt gerne noch eine Sache fragen, und das ist dieses Gerät, das ihr verschenkt, diese Freedom Fighter Box. Das ist ja sagen, ein Router, der das komplette Internet dann nach Schweden lenkt. Jetzt würde ich das möglicherweise denken, okay, ich würde mir das für zu Hause nachbauen, aber eigentlich finde ich es nicht so geil, dass ich dann sozusagen, wenn ich zu Hause an meinem dicken Internetanschluss sitze, dass ich dann auch irgendwie dieses Schwedending nutze, kann man das auch irgendwie teilen? Dass man sagt, okay, hier, dieser Teil meines WLANs ist öffentlich und geht nach Schweden, und der andere Teil, der ist für mich privat, der darf ich schön dick sein.
Ja, das kann man, also meistens ausgesetzt, man kann's, dann kann man's. Also der erste Schritt ist mit Sicherheit, ein offenes Betriebssystem auf den Router zuflaschen, also die Firmware auszutauschen, zum Beispiel OpenWRT, ganz hervorragend, und dann einen AccessPoint zu verwenden, dessen WLAN-Chip mir ermöglicht, mehrere virtuelle WLAN-AccessPoints einzurichten. Also das heißt, ich hab da vielleicht nur einen WLAN-Chip in meinem AccessPoint, aber softwaregesteuert kann ich den eben in verschiedene virtuelle Netze aufteilen. Und eins davon kann dann mein verschlüsseltes WLAN-Netz sein, was ich privat nutze, und das andere kann ein offenes WLAN-Netz sein. Und durch entsprechende Routing-Einträge könnte ich dann den einen Teil über meinen normalen Internetzugang routen und den anderen Teil eben über den VPN-Tunnel routen.
So, jetzt hast du gerade schon gesagt, das könnte man, wenn man das kann, mit dem OPEN-WRT und so. Das gibt aber sozusagen, es gibt noch keinen Markt dafür. Das heißt, ich kann nicht hingehen und sagen, so, könnten sie mir bitte so einen Router geben, der das kann.
Naja, also das Skandal ist, dass es dafür einen wachsenden, und zwar explosionsartig wachsenden Markt gibt, weil nämlich den professionellen Mobilfunkanbietern die Bandbreite ausgeht in ihren UNTS-Netzen und in anderen europäischen Ländern bereits als Internetanbieter oder Telekons halt mir so einen WLAN-Router anbieten, wo sie genau das machen. Und dann den einen Teil des Internetzugangs, den ich kaufe, der steht dann mir zur Verfügung, und den anderen Teil meines Internetzugangs verleihen oder verkaufen die dann eben an ihre Nutzer, die dann, also statt halt über ihr Handy, über UMTS zu surfen, dann halt über meinen privaten WLAN-Anschluss surfen dürfen.
Aber das ist dann so eingerichtet, dass ich davon keine einen Bußen habe? Interessant, gibt es aber in Deutschland anscheinend noch nicht so viel.
Nee, in Deutschland ist auch für dieses Moment in der Pilotphase und auch denen, auch die stoßen auf die Störerhaftung und haben sich halt bei dem Pilotversuch, der auch von den Mitteln der Europäischen Union gefördert wird, mit vier Millionen für Spanien und Portugal entschieden, weil sie in Deutschland juristische Probleme gesehen haben, eben unter anderem die Störerhaftung. Also die Störerhaftung ist für niemanden eigentlich eine gute Idee, außer für die Anwaltskanzleien, die davon profitieren.
Betrifft diese Störerhaftung dann die Privatperson, bei der jetzt der Router steht, um denen es dann gerade ging oder betrifft es dann die große Firma?
Ja, das ist halt die Frage. Der Internet Provider, das ist ja auch das Gemeine, dass der Internet Provider halt eine Ausnahme ist und an sich nicht der Störerhaftung unterliegt. Also wer sich bei der Bundesnetzagentur als Access Provider anmelden kann, weil er gewerblich einen Internetzugang anbietet, der fällt nicht unter die Störerhaftung, aber Privatpersonen tun das halt leider.
Okay, das ist ein wichtiger Unterschied, über den wir gleich noch mal sprechen wollen, weil genau darauf zielt der Gesetzesvorschlag von der digitalen Gesellschaft ab. Jetzt würde ich ganz kurz nochmal dieses Ding einflächten, weil das in der Diskussion um File Sharing und Abmahnung kommt das immer wieder vor, dass Leute sagen, es ist doch nur das Hochladen illegal, nicht das Runterladen. Ich kenne dazu zwei Antworten. Die eine ist, wenn man zum Beispiel sowas wie BitTorrent macht, dann ist Hochladen immer gleich Runterladen. Also man kann das sozusagen nicht wirklich trennen. Und die andere ist, dass es wohl irgendwann mal eine Gesetzesänderung gab, die sagt, wenn du aus einer offensichtlich rechtswidrigen Quelle runterliegst, dann bist du auch dran und da das Internet eine Gefahrenzone ist, gehe ich mal fast davon aus, dass eigentlich alles eine offensichtliche rechtswidrige Quelle ist. Aber wir haben ja glücklicherweise Bea hier. Kannst du uns dazu etwas genaueres sagen, wie das mit dem hohen Runterladen sich verhält?
Genau. Also das ist jetzt nicht Gesetz, sondern Rechtsprechung. Das ist für uns ja immer so wichtig, das zu trennen. Und zwar ist man dahin gegangen zu sagen, also im Gesetz steht schon, na egal, ja. Es geht darum, dass als Nutze ich erkennen können muss, ob mir jemand, also der Rechteinhaber, ob der das frei zugänglich macht oder eben, dass der Rechte drauf geschlossen sind. Oh Gott, das war eine schlechte Erklärung. Also es gibt ja natürlich sehr viel Werke, Filme, Musik etc. wo keine Urheberrechte drauf sind oder die halt eben für jeden frei zugänglich machen.
Also die man runterladen darf.
Genau, was legal ist. Und dann gibt es die illegalen. Und wenn es evident ist, also offensichtlich ist, dass es illegal ist, dann verstoße ich eben auch mit dem Runterladen gegen Urheberrechte.
Und dann streiten sich wahrscheinlich...
Nein, man streitet sich leider nicht, sondern macht das ganz einfach. Das gibt die Plattform, wo ich einfach Daten teile. Da muss ich dann als Nutzer davon ausgehen, dass das illegal ist. So einfach machen sich die Richter.
Also wenn es irgendwo nicht verfügbar ist, ist es illegal?
Heutzutage sieht man ja da eh schon noch dieses fiese GEMA-Grinsen, wenn man versucht auf YouTube sich Dinge, die...
Ach so, wenn es denn überhaupt verfügbar ist, muss es ja illegal sein.
Also es geht um die Portale. Wenn ich mir, was weiß ich, bei Ripple Share dann eben das Webiber runter lade, dann muss ich einfach davon ausgehen, ich muss wissen, dass es illegal ist. Das ist so eine Annahme, wird auch mit nichts begründet wirklich. Sondern das ist diese Sichtweise, die eben auch angesprochen wurde. Richter sehen eben immer nur die Verletzer, die Paar und schließen dann darauf auf die ganze Gesellschaft.
Okay, Jürgen, ich hoffe, das hat deine Frage jetzt beantwortet. Dann dir auch vielen Dank für das kurze Erklären der Freedom Fighter Box. Wird es noch mal so eine Aktion geben? Oder war das jetzt dann ein einmaliges Ding und ihr hofft, dass jetzt alles gut wird?
Das war jetzt erstmal ein einmaliges Ding und 100 Router können jetzt auch nicht die Antwort sein. Es ging eigentlich einfach nur mal darum, exemplarisch aufzuzeigen, dass es Wege aus der Steuererhaftung gibt und wie sinnlos das eigentlich auch ist. Es gibt aber noch andere Wege aus der Steuererhaftung. Die idea ja auch schon mal angeschnitten hat am Anfang, dass ich eben zum Beispiel auf meinem Router so eine Splashpage mache und so Hinweise gebe, wie ich erwarte, dass der Nutzer, der jetzt da anonym ins Netz geht, sich im Internet so verhalten hat und dass ich vielleicht auch sogar technische Maßnahmen treffe, die Filesharing einschränken oder ich versuche, die einzuschränken. Bei Freifunk haben wir ein sogenanntes Zappscript, was halt so guckt, ein bisschen analysiert wird hier, möglicherweise Filesharing gemacht, weil eben bestimmte Ports geöffnet werden und dann versucht das Script, diesen Verkehr zu filtern. Und das dritte ist, dass ich für all dies Zeugen habe, möglichst viele, die auch bestätigen können, dass dieser WLAN-Router eben tatsächlich ein Freifunk-Router ist, dass der der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung steht und dass ich den so eingerichtet habe. Und dann stehen auch die Chancen sehr gut, dass man gegen so eine Abmahnkanzlei eigentlich anstinken könnte.
Okay, die Chancen stehen sehr gut, das glaube ich sozusagen das Wichtige. Und wir werden jetzt gleich mal darüber sprechen, wie man das ganze Problem vielleicht aus der Welt schaffen könnte. Es gibt ja zumindest einen Vorschlag. Jürgen, dir erstmal vielen Dank. Viel Spaß noch. Bis dann. So, und jetzt kommen wir zu dem eigentlichen Anlass des heutigen Chaos Rades. Und das ist halt dieser Gesetzesvorschlag der digitalen Gesellschaft zur Aufhebung der Störerhaftung für Privatpersonen, wenn ich das jetzt richtig formuliert habe. Wir haben gerade schon gehört von Jürgen, wenn ich ein Internetprovider bin, dann falle ich gar nicht unter diese Störerhaftung, sondern dann bin ich wahrscheinlich nur verpflichtet, irgendwie sozusagen gewisse Informationen weiterzugeben, wenn die mir zustehen. Als jemand, der sein WLAN aufmacht, bin ich ja, könnte man argumentieren, ein kleiner Internetprovider, aber dann unterlege ich trotzdem der Störerhaftung. Und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist der Vorschlag der digitalen Gesellschaft genau zu sagen, kleine Internetprovider sind genau dasselbe, wie große Internetprovider. Was genau steht da drin, Bea?
Das wird Paragraph 8 Telemediengesetz ergänzt oder soll ergänzt werden. Und für die Betreiber soll ausgeschlossen werden, dass sie haften für die Tätigkeiten, die dann die User im Internet machen. Und das ist der ersten Satz, der ergänzt werden soll. Und am zweiten soll sich die ganze Geschichte auch auf die Unterlassensansprüche besitzen. Also Störerhaftung ist ein Anspruch auf Unterlassen. Wir haben ja, erinnert euch, die ganze Schadensersatzgeschichte ausgeschlossen. Die fällt ja sowieso weg. Und Störerhaftung ist eben, dass man das unterlässt. Hier kausal daran teilzunehmen, dass diese Verletzungen begangen werden. Und dieser Ausschluss, also dieses Privileg, eben Haftungsprivileg, soll sich auch auf diese Unterlassungsansprüche, also die Störerhaftung beziehen.
Jetzt nochmal bitte normal verständlich.
Ich würde interessieren, was es bedeutet, wenn man als Störer in Haftung genommen wird, so dann finanziell im Gegensatz zu den Verfahren, in denen man selber schädigender sein soll.
Der Schadensersatz ist die Lizenzgebühr. Und unterlassen bedeutet, ich muss diese Erklärung unterschreiben und habe die Anwaltsgebühren. Noch Fragen? Also es ist ein bisschen weniger. Also die Unterlassungserklärung könnte man eigentlich auch ohne Anwaltskosten, wenn man...
Ich hab das Gefühl, wir verlassen gerade ein bisschen dem Vater, über das wir eigentlich reden.
Ich find das schon spannend, dass wenn man einfach nur als Störer dahingestellt wird und nicht selber als Schuldiger, inwieweit das einem dann Ärger erspart.
Da tut es ja eben nicht, darüber haben wir die ganze Zeit schon geredet.
Also doch, es ist schon weniger. Also die Kosten zumindest, die auf einen zukommen, sind weniger.
Aber es sind Kosten.
Es sind Kosten, es sind nur die Anwaltskosten. Bei der Störerhaftung kommen nur die Anwaltskosten auf einen zu.
Die ja auch schon hoch genug sind. Jetzt aber noch mal zurück zu diesem Gesetzesvorschlag. Noch mal heißt es richtig, ich mache meinen Wählern auf, bin deswegen sozusagen dann, also laut diesem Gesetzesvorschlag, ein Betreiber und muss dann sozusagen nicht mehr als Störer haften.
Richtig, genau.
Jetzt haben die diesen Gesetzesvorschlag sozusagen vorgeschlagen. Wie wahrscheinlich ist es denn, dass der so von irgendjemand übernommen wird?
So wie er jetzt steht, ist es ein Beginn. Wir haben aber hier ein großes Problem. Und zwar sind Grundrechte, die aufeinandertreffen. Also wir haben die Grundrechte, die Eigentumsrechte von den Urhebern. Und wir haben Grundrechte von den Nutzern. Meinungsfreiheit zum Beispiel, ganz groß. Wissenschaftsfreiheit, solche Sachen. Und die Problematik mit Grundrechten ist, man darf nicht zu dem, oder man kann einfach nicht zu dem Ergebnis kommen, dass einer auf sein Grundrecht verzichten muss. Sondern muss einen Kompromiss machen. Das heißt praktische Konkordanz für diejenigen, die sich für sowas interessieren. Das komplett Ausschließen, diese Störerhaftung wird man nicht schaffen. Sondern man muss es sauber herausarbeiten, unter welchen Umständen man in eine Störerhaftung reinkommen kann. Also man braucht einen Kompromiss.
Ja, aber das heißt auch sozusagen, weil ein Kompromiss immer bedeutet, das ist dann die Beweis, die da bei mir steht, man kann das im Prinzip also nicht wirklich ausschließen, dass ich als Störerhafter verhaftet werde.
Na ja gut, also ich kann fast gar nichts komplett ausschließen. Aber ich muss es konkretisieren. Wir haben das jetzt weder in der Rechtsprechung noch in Gesetzen. Haben wir das konkretisiert. Wann komme ich denn in die Störerhaftung? Was halt nicht sein kann in dem Moment, wo ich einen Dritten in meinem Internetzugang nutzen lasse, dass ich sofort als Störer in die Haftung genommen werden kann. Das geht nicht, das funktioniert nicht. Also da ist dann der Verlust von Grundrechten auf der User Seite.
Das ist aber so, wie es gerade funktioniert.
Richtig.
Was sind denn, also gibt es schon Vorschläge? Also auf der einen Seite ist es sozusagen, wenn ich meinen WLAN anbiete, dann bin ich automatisch Störer. Die andere Seite, der Gesetzesvorschlag sagt, ich bin auf gar keinen Fall Störer. Du sagst jetzt, man müsste das irgendwie ausarbeiten. Gibt es da schon konkrete Vorschläge, dass man sagt, okay, du kannst deinen WLAN aufmachen. Wenn du das und das beachtest, bist du kein Störer.
Wir waren letzte Woche im Abgeordnetenhaus, also vom Freifunk. Wir wurden von den Grünen eingeladen. Das wurde diskutiert, wie man eben auf politischer Ebene, also das heißt im Bundestag diese Störerhaftung, irgendwie im Krockene Tücher bekommt. Man arbeitet daran. Es ist aber juristisch, gibt es keine schwierige Aufgabe als Interessenabwägung. Das ist einfach so. Man muss in den Kern rein, was für Pflichten hat derjenige, der seinen Internetzugang anderen zur Verfügung stellt. Es macht Sinn, die Analogie aus dieser Haftungsprivilegierung vom Telemediengesetz zu nehmen. Wir haben aber so eine riesen Industrie, ein riesen Lobby dahinter.
Ich versuch das jetzt einfach mal so zu be- Für mich ist das W-Laden meinen Nachbarn und meinen Besuchern anzubieten, ohne ihnen vorher Schriftstücke unterscheiden zu lassen, ohne ihre Personalausweise vorlegen zu lassen, ist für mich einfach so ein Akt der Gastfreundlichkeit. Dass mir das dann jetzt daraus ein Strick gedreht wird, finde ich politisch überhaupt, ja, sozial und gesellschaftlich, finde ich irgendwie eine kraftale Katastrophe, dass ich irgendwie diesen selbstverständlichen Akt der Gastfreundschaft nicht mehr bereiten darf. Und auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich auch das Problem, dass generell anonyme Zugänge zum Internet im Ausland immer verdammt hochgehalten werden. Dass wenn man sich gegen fiese Diktaturen im Ausland zur Wehr setzen muss, dann muss es einfach für alle Leute die Möglichkeit geben, das Internet anonym zu benutzen. Und gerade in Deutschland, wo wir hier die lupende Demokratur haben, hier ist aber am besten nur die Gefahrenzone, Internet zu benutzen, nachdem du dich dort einmal biometrisch mit Proktometrie identifiziert hast. Dann darfst du erst das Internet benutzen. Und das ist einfach ein unhaltbarer Zustand. Also heutzutage, ja, die Tor gibt es, aber Tor ist immer noch eine Krücke. Und es gibt aktive Gegenbewegungen von Verwertungsinhabern, auch aus der Politik, die einfach nicht wollen, dass Menschen am Internet anonymen Teil haben. Und da muss man einfach erst mal das Bewusstsein schärfen, bevor man dann im Detail dort auch juristisch oder politisch dagegen vorgeht. Erst mal...
Das heißt, du würdest eigentlich nur die extreme Lösung akzeptieren und sagen, Privatversuche sind keine Störer?
Ich würde erst mal die komplette Idee, dass einfach Menschen Internet anzubieten, dass das eigentlich ein Grundrecht sein sollte, wie der Wanderer kommt an der Hütte vorbei, kriegt ein Glas Wasser, wie der Netznomade kommt an meinem Zuhause vorbei, kriegt irgendwie 64 Kilo mit, damit er sich seine E-Mails runterladen kann. Das ist für mich eigentlich total selbstverständlich.
Könnte man aber sagen, so politisch Realismus ist, dass das möglicherweise nicht durchkommt.
Was heißt, naja, ich meine trotzdem kann man ja erstmal einen Konsens haben, dass das prinzipiell eine gute Idee ist und dann versuchen daran, die Entscheidungen zu auszurichten und nicht bloß die seltsam verkorksten Weltbilder von irgendwelchen Richtern, die aus dem Internet nur das Böse kommen sehen, dort als Maß aller Dinge anzulegen.
Ja, aber jetzt hat der Jürgen von den Freifunkern gerade erzählt, es gibt diese ganzen Sachen, dass man sagen kann, hier, bevor du meinen Freispieler benutzt, kriegst du so eine Seite angezeigt, sei nicht böse, da ist der Zeigefinger. Kann so was reichen? Werden solche konkreten Schritte überhaupt schon diskutiert? Oder muss es irgendwie was anderes sein? Tatsächlich sowas wie, man darf nur das anbieten, wenn die Leute sich einloggen und irgendwie identifizieren müssen.
Das, was Jürgen gesagt hat, das stammt aus der Rechtbrechung auch. Also diese Prüfpflicht bezieht sich darauf, dass ich denjenigen, der mein Internetzugang benutzt, dass ich ihn belehre, dass ich ihn darüber in Kenntnis setze, was er im Internet nicht zu machen hat. Dann eben auch diese ganzen technischen Sachen. Das Problem ist, das läuft halt alles schon so lange, Jahre. Und wenn man jetzt Erdgeist zuhört, wird einem auch schon wieder klar, dass die Fronten sich so verherzt haben. GEMA macht unfassbare Werbung gegen die, gegen das freie Internet. Also hier wird ja kaum inhaltlich wirklich darüber gesprochen, was das Problem ist. Sondern jeder sagt auf der einen Seite, das muss alles kontrolliert werden. Und auf der anderen Seite, das darf nicht kontrolliert werden. Das wird auch nicht in der Gesellschaft darüber richtig diskutiert. Ich bin jetzt auch nicht hier und kann sagen, was die Lösung ist der Störerhaftung.
Aber möglicherweise gibt es eine Idee wenigstens.
Also ich tue mich sogar schwer mit dieser Splashpage. Also das ist jetzt bei über Freifunk dann zu schreiben, was in der ganzen Sache ist und was eben auch, was wir denken, ist wichtig, einen anonymen Zugang zum Internet. Aber auf der anderen Seite, das sind alles mündige Dritte. Das sind keine Kinder. Also da tue ich mich schon schwer zu sagen. Ich habe jetzt Sonderwissen, weil ich einen Internetzugang habe. Also ja, weil ich der Anschlussinhaber bin.
Aber das hört sich jetzt für mich ein bisschen so an, wie das Problem ist eigentlich unlösbar.
Nein, das Problem ist nicht unlösbar. Es gibt aus Russland dieses Pirate Pay. Habt ihr das mal gehört? Damit sollen die Daten, ueberrechtlich die geschützt sind, sollen die auch technisch geschützt sein. Also es soll halt irgendwie, also ich bin kein Techniker, aber das soll so funktionieren, dass sie, wenn illegal up und down gelautet wird, dass sie irgendwie automatisch gelöscht oder gesperrt werden.
Das funktioniert doch nicht.
Sowas würde ich mir auch mein Rechner nicht installieren wollen.
Das ist auch so ein Knackpunkt. Bloß weil die Verwertungsgesellschaften ihre Daten nicht schützen können, sorgen sie dafür, dass man einen Kontrollnetz bekommt. Oder dass wir halt einen Kontrollnetz bekommen. Das funktioniert halt nicht. Also nicht so, nicht mit diesen harten Fronten.
Ich sehe ja da irgendwie die harten Fronten nicht, sondern ich finde jetzt, dass meine Idee, dass ich mein Internet einfach gerne Nachbarn und Freunden zur Verfügung stelle, sehe ich ein wenig mal als eine extrem harte Position an. Das ist einfach so mein Gefühl, wie ich für mich Netznachbarschaft definiere. Das Ding ist aber, dass man diese Fronten einfach total leicht entschärfen kann. Also es hat sich gezeigt in den letzten Jahren, dass diesen ganzen Urheberrechtskleinkrieg, der eigentlich Bürgerkrieg, den also ein einzelne Kanzlein gegen die Falscherer führen, dass man den entschärfen kann, indem man einfach total bequeme und gängelungsfreie Möglichkeiten diese Informationen aus dem Netz zu beziehen. Und zwar kein schlechteres Produkt, als was man aus den Tauschbörsen bekommt. Das funktioniert total toll. Hat Apple gezeigt, hat so einen Music Store aufgemacht, die Leute zahlen sich da dumm und dämlich und machen das, weil es einfach total bequem ist und weil sie es einfach auf ihren bunten Eistern, die weiß es, benutzen können. Machen sie es einfach und die Anzahl der Musik, die die Leute, die dort sich die Musik runterladen, dann auch aus den falschen Ringbörsen besorgen, ist da, glaube ich, verschwindend gering. Und da hat, ja, wie altes Mantra, die Urheberrechts- und Verwertungsindustrie einfach verschlafen, entspannte Angebote den Kunden anzubieten und in diese Nische, in diese Marktlücke, die sie gelassen haben, springen jetzt da auch immer wieder neue Dienste, die das, ja, öffnungszeitenfreie und ohne irgendwelche FBI-Warnings Vorspenne seinen Film nur beziehen. Das hast du alles nicht, wenn du dir aus Pirate Bay deine Musik kriegst.
Das ist aber schon wieder die große gesellschaftliche Diskussion, die ja das konkrete Problem nicht angeht, weil es möglicherweise, egal wie gut wir das gestalten, oder die Verwertungsindustrie das gestalten, es immer Leute gibt, die möglicherweise Raubbau und Kopien doch total super finden. Wir sprechen gleich darüber weiter. Wir müssen jetzt erst mal einen kurzen Break machen mit dem Fritz Infobot Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Danach könnt ihr gerne noch mal anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Ich möchte heute gerne noch eine Lösung für dieses Störerfunkproblem hier haben.
Fritz und Festivals.
Es ist sowas wie die Perle unter den Festivals. Drei Tage Sommer, Sonne, Strand und Meer. Also für Sommer und Sonne können wir nicht garantieren. Aber für Meer. Das Helene Beach Festival. Mit mehr als 100 DJs und Bands. Auch mehr als vier Bühnen. Nämlich fünf. Und darauf stehen Lexi und Cape Hall und Busse.
Oliver Kolecki und Kraftklub. Und viele viele mehr.
Das Helene Beach Festival. Von morgen bis Sonntag. Am Helene See bei Frankfurt Oder.
Die letzten Tickets zum dabei sein gibt es diese Woche bei den Radio Fritzen und bei Fritz im Netz.
Das Helene Beach Festival. Drei Tage Sommer Sonne Strand aber vor allem Meer.
Nachricht. Mitteljahre groß.
EU-Kommissionschef Barroso hat Griechenland versichert, dass es auf die Hilfe der anderen EU-Länder zählen kann. Allerdings müsse Athen auch seine Verpflichtungen gegenüber den Gläubigern erfüllen, sagte Barroso nach einem Gespräch mit Ministerpräsident Samaras. Barroso betonte, der Verbleib Griechenlands in der Eurozone sei der einzige Weg, den Schwächeren zu helfen. Die Polizei hat erneut Räume der Health Angels durchsucht. Rund 300 Beamte waren am Donnerstagabend in 16 Wohnungen in Berlin, Brandenburg und Sachsen-Anhalt, sowie in den Vereinsräumen der Health Angels in Potsdam im Einsatz. Es seien zahlreiche Waffen sowie Betäubungsmittel und Anabolika gefunden worden. Festnahmen soll es keine gegeben haben. Die US-Regierung und die amerikanische Börsenaufsicht ermitteln gegen die Rating-Agentur Standard & Poor's. Wie der Mutterkonzern der Rating-Agentur McGraw-Hill mitteilte, wird untersucht, ob Standard & Poor's bei der Bewertung bestimmter Investitionen gegen die Gesetze verstoßen hat. Gleichzeitig kündigte McGraw-Hill an, sich gegen die Anschuldigungen zur Wehr zu setzen. Den Agenturinnen wird vorgeworfen, mit ungerechtfertigt hohen Bewertungen von Hypothekenpaketen die Immobilienkrise in den USA angefacht zu haben. In Moskau hat die Opposition friedlich gegen den zunehmenden Druck auf Andersdenkende in Russland demonstriert. Die rund 3000 Teilnehmer forderten vor allem die Freilassung von oppositionellen, die nach einer Kundgebung am 6. Mai festgenommen worden waren. Das berichtete der Radiosänger Sender Echo Moskvi. Damals hatten zehntausende Menschen gegen die dritte Amtszeit von Präsident Putin demonstriert. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin sind es zwischen 22 und 25 Grad, in Angermünde und Wittenberge 20, Potsdam, Frankfurt, Neuropin 22 und im Cottbus 23 Grad. In der Nacht bleibt es größtenteils trocken und die Temperaturen sinken weiter auf bis zu 18 bis 13 Grad. Morgen dann wieder ganz viel Sonne, bei Temperaturen bis 32 Grad. Zum Abend kann es dann vereinzelt Wärmegewitter geben.
Verkehr.
Nach Brandenburg, die A12, Berlin Richtung Frankfurt oder zwischen der Raststätte Biegener Helden Süd und Frankfurt oder West steht auf der rechten Spur ein kaputter Laster. Passt da auf und gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de und das Augehört mit man.
Heute Chaosradio mit Erdgeist Bea und Kai. Es geht um Störerhaftung, also die Art und Weise, wie ihr mitverantwortlich gemacht werdet, wenn ihr euer WLAN aufmacht und darüber jemand anderes was runterlebt oder möglicherweise habt ihr euer WLAN auch nicht aufgemacht. Wie das passiert, kann uns auch Martin erzählen. Dem ist das nämlich passiert. Martin aus Charlottenburg. Hallo und guten Abend. Sag doch mal genau, was bei dir passiert ist.
Ja, also direkt offenes WLAN war es nicht. Aber natürlich dieses besagte legendäre Anwaltschreiben über den Download einer Datei. In dem Fall soll es sich um eine SIP-Datei gehandelt haben mit 99 Megabyte, der größten Hits der 80er. Und da gab es auch dieses berühmt berüchtigte Anwaltschreiben. Und zwar in dem Fall vom Rechtsvertreter von Bushido. Denn Bushido hat das Copyright für einige Porno-Firme, was ebenfalls im Anwaltschreiben erwähnt wird. Und unter anderem auch als Produzent für einige Songs und Lieder und Hits. Und eines dieser Lieder in diesem großen Paket, da hat er das Copyright drauf und daraufhin hat der Anwalt abgemahnt.
Und du bist dir sicher, du hast nicht 99 Megabyte Super Hits der 80er runtergeladen?
Ja, wir waren uns nicht ganz sicher, weil wir sind halt eine WG. Und tatsächlich haben wir mal so ein paar alte Schallplatten entsorgt. Dann haben wir gesagt, ach Mensch, die Lieder hätten wir aber noch ganz gern. Und haben dann versucht eben diese Lieder noch mal runterzuladen. Und so direkt einzeln gab es die gar nicht mehr. Aber dann gab es halt durchaus auch mal solche Pakete, wo die gesuchten Lieder mit dabei waren. Und deswegen können wir das nicht ganz hundertprozentig ausschließen. Ja, wirklich, weil ich ja Anschlussinhaber bin und ich selber weiß, ich war es nicht. Aber ich kann nicht hundertprozentig sagen, ob nicht meine Mitbewohner da eventuell diesen Schaden verursacht haben. Und insofern habe ich da mal meinen Anwalt eingeschaltet. Ich habe ihn mir halt geleistet. Der war da auch ganz kulant. Der hat nämlich einfach das Standardantwort. Er hat einfach klar gesagt, okay, Unterlassungserklärung nicht unterschreiben. Stattdessen statt den geforderten 350 Euro halt freiwillig 150 Euro überweisen und anbieten, das vorgefertigte, wie auch das modifizierte Unterlassungserklärung ausfüllen, abschicken. Und gut ist es. Das heißt, also unterm Strich habe ich 100 Euro gespart. Ja, Geld ausgegeben und noch gespart.
Du hast da deine Mitbewohner offensichtlich nicht ausreichend im Benutzen des Internets geschult und vielleicht noch mal mit Nachdruck auf ihre Rechte und Pflichten in dieser potenziellen Gefahrenzone oder Schadenszone hingewiesen.
Nein, wirklich nicht. Aber wir können sagen, seitdem sind wir von BitTorrent und Co relativ abstinent.
Aber man muss sich das mal überlegen. Also die Schallplatten, um die es euch da ging, die hattet ihr ja eigentlich da im Vorfeld schon erworben und habt die jetzt eigentlich nur noch mal aus dem Internet runterladen wollen und der wirklich entstandene Schaden für Bushide ist ja eigentlich null, weil ihr wolltet seine Musik gar nicht haben oder respektive deine Mitbewohner wollten die nicht haben und das ist das einzige, was da jetzt bei euch dann auf den Rechnern oder bei den Mitbewohnern eventuell auf den Rechnern gelandet ist, sind Musikdateien für die, die schon ursprünglich Geld ausgegeben hatten.
Ja genau und zumal ich auch sagen kann, dass in den Jahren hat sie sicherlich eher noch nicht Musik gemacht und ich jetzt persönlich auch auf seine Werke durchaus verzichten kann, kann ich mit 100 Prozent der Sicherheit sagen, okay, die Datei hab ich nicht behalten.
Also die andere spannende Frage, es geht ja heute um Störerhaftung. Nehmen wir mal den Fall, das wäre tatsächlich so, dass es die nicht gäbe. Hättest du dich dann vielleicht hingesetzt gesagt, ja entschuldigt, das waren wir nicht, weißt du uns das erstmal nach?
Ja, durchaus. Also ich benutze natürlich und betreibe auch ein WLAN, das ist natürlich auch verschlüsselt bis zum Abwinken, aber natürlich habe ich dann auch überlegt, ob man da besser so argumentieren sollte, habe dann trotzdem erstmal umgefragt und kam dann so von wegen, es kann schon sein, dass ich da so was runtergeladen habe. Und deswegen haben wir dann gesagt, okay wir fragen den Anwalt und der Anwalt hat uns dann eigentlich rechtzügig dazu geraten, das einfach zu machen.
Da kann man natürlich sagen, politisch auch in Erklärungsschwierigkeiten, wenn dann so ein Fall vorgeführt wird. Oder wenn man sagt, okay wir schaffen die Störerhaftung ab, aber was ist denn genau dann mit so einen Leuten?
Ja, das ist definitiv ein Problem. Ich bin da auch ganz ehrlich oder sagen wir mal, bis vor kurzem habe ich berühmte, berüchtigte Film- und Serienwebseiten nicht besucht. Habe tatsächlich versucht immer, wenn ich was gucken wollte, die offiziellen Quellen zu nutzen, aber tatsächlich enthalten die immer nur den Kram von aktuell und nicht das, was man halt gerade aktuell gucken möchte. Bin dann schließlich endlich doch wieder auf einem Klon dieser vergangenen goldenen Tage gestoßen und tatsächlich, früher habe ich es nie gemacht, jetzt mache ich es halt wieder regelmäßig. Einfach deswegen, weil ich gar keine legale Möglichkeit habe, mir anzugucken, was ich gerade haben will.
Aber das ist ja das, was Erdgeist sagte, wenn du einen hättest, würdest du da auch Geld dafür ausgeben? Martin, vielen Dank für deine Geschichte und das praktische Beispiel. So kann es gehen. Wir driften jetzt so ein bisschen in diese Filesharing is evil or not-Ecke ab. Ich würde gerne noch mal bei dem offenen WLAN bleiben, weil wir sagen, das eigentliche Thema war ja dieses zur Verfügung stellen von Infrastrukturen für die Allgemeinheit. Und eine häufige Frage. Also, was wir jetzt gelernt haben, ist zu sagen, diese Störhaftung kriegen wir anscheinend nicht politisch geklärt. Unsere gestudierte Rechtsvertreterin sagt, naja, das ist relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass wir das irgendwie so in der Lebenszeit hinkriegen vielleicht. Mal abgesehen davon, gibt es ja diese Idee, das WLAN aufzumachen trotzdem und manche Leute sagen so, wie Erdgeist sagen so, das ist für mich einfach, das gehört sich für mich so, das ist eine Höflichkeit, mein WLAN auch anderen Leuten anzubieten. Eine häufige Angst, die ich bei Leuten erlebe, ist nicht nur das, das politische, das juristische, sondern auch, dass sie sagen so, wenn ich meinen WLAN aufmache, gewähre ich da nicht hackern noch extra freien Zugriff auf meinen Rechner. Also einfach die Angst, da technisch was falsch zu machen, wenn man das wieder aufmacht. Wie sieht es denn damit aus? Aha, gut.
Aber das tut man ja in vielen Fällen. Ist die Gefahr eigentlich eher aus dem Internet, ist die Gefahr eigentlich eher aus Attacken, die passieren, wenn man Webseiten besucht und von irgendwelchen Targeted Attacks, von Leuten, die jetzt wirklich rumfahren, Wardriven und auf die WLANs dazugreifen. Ja, habe ich noch nicht gehört. Es gibt, wenn ich jetzt Firma bin, dann würde ich mir das vielleicht überlegen, ob ich dann extra Gästenetzwerk anbiete, was ich nochmal physikalisch trenne.
Lass uns mal bitte nochmal ganz einfach machen. Die einfache Frage ist ja erstmal, wenn ich jemand, also wenn ich einen WLAN aufmache, dann erlaube ich ja demjenigen Zutritt zu meinem lokalen Netzwerk. Bin ich dann angreifbarer oder nicht?
Kommt ganz drauf an, wie du das Netzwerk konfigurierst. Das kommt drauf an. Ich bin jetzt auch mal Jurist.
Okay, ihr verdammten Juristen. Ganz normaler Typ holt sich ein Windows-Rechner, patcht den, weil Microsoft das ja irgendwie anbietet, macht dann sein WLAN auf.
Also wenn das WLAN dann unverschlüsselt ist, so richtig offen, also es gibt ja einmal die Variante, zum Beispiel das Café hängt dann ein A4-Zettel hin mit WLAN-Name und Passwort.
Nee, nee, nee, ich würde sagen, jetzt richtig.
Aber so richtig offen, das heißt dann auch, dass die gesamte Kommunikation vom Rechner zum Internet unverschlüsselt läuft und auch dadurch vulnerable ist. Also du kannst dich dann zum Beispiel dahinstellen und die E-Mail-Provider-Webseite vorspielen und die Passwörter abgreifen, wenn das nicht ordentlich verschlüsselt ist.
Das heißt, okay, da müsste man, müsste also der Benutzer auf seinen Rechner darauf achten, dass er sozusagen immer brav alles schon von sich aus verschlüsselt.
Genau.
Jetzt hast du gerade gesagt, wenn ich dir das WLAN verschlüsselte, aber das Passwort angebe, dann ist das irgendwie anders.
Ja, dann ist halt die Kommunikation verschlüsselt, aber wie das dann mit der Störerhaftung ist, weiß ich nicht genau.
Nee, nee, nee, es geht nicht um die Störerhaftung. Es geht jetzt erst mal sozusagen, an dieser Stelle tatsächlich nur um den technischen Aspekt.
Der technische Aspekt ist, dass dann für jeden einzelnen Client, also für jeden einzelnen Teilnehmer in dem WLAN ein eigener Session Key ausgehandelt wird und man kann die Pakete der anderen üblicherweise nicht entschlüsseln. Man sieht aber die IP-Adressen der anderen Leute innerhalb des LANs, kann dann, wenn man die angreifen möchte, kann man die dann auch, wenn man geroutet wird, also wenn man nicht direkt ins Internet geroutet wird, sondern auch noch innerhalb des LANs, kann man natürlich dann Angriffe auch versuchen.
Also das ist eh so ein Angriffsfall, der immer vorhanden ist, sobald man halt den fremden Access Point nutzt. Also man muss halt selbst entscheiden, ob man demjenigen vertraut, von dem man das Internet benutzt oder nicht, weil es kann jetzt auch jeder sein, wenn es irgendwie halt hochverschlüsselt ist, dass trotzdem der Access Point Betreiber irgendwie jetzt einen kriminellen Hintergedanken hat und die Kommunikation mitschneidet oder...
Ja, okay, das geht in beide Richtungen. Aber nun müssen wir mal sagen, bei dem konkreten Fall zu bleiben, es wäre also sozusagen schon ein kleines bisschen sicherer, wenn ich meinen WLAN öffentlich zur Verfügung stellen will, wenn ich sozusagen in die... es gibt ja diese SSID, also wenn ich meinen Rechner aufklappe und mir die WLANs anzeigen lasse, ich könnte also meine WLAN nehmen, das WPA2 verschlüsseln und in diesen Namen, der angezeigt wird, schreiben, so irgendwie Username, so. Nee, einfach nur das Passwort. Also Passwort für dieses WLAN ist so und so. Dann hätte ich zumindest schon mal, dass der Verkehr innerhalb des Netzwerks verschlüsselt ist. Okay. Könnt ihr also, wenn ihr das wollt, könnt ihr das zum Beispiel so machen. Jetzt hört sich das natürlich so an, okay, wir sind jetzt in diesem lokalen Netzwerk drin und deswegen machen wir uns angreifbarer. Man muss aber auch mal deutlich sagen, das ist genau dieselbe Szenerie, genau dieselbe Situation, wie wenn ich in einen Café gehe und dort den Rechner aufklappe.
Oder gar fremde Rechner benutzt in einem Internetcafé.
Also ein klassisches Beispiel, man vergisst sich bei Facebook auszuloggen im Internetcafé oder zum Beispiel, dass man soweit geht und sagt, jemand gaukelt halt vor, dass sein Rechner jetzt Facebook ist und du loggst dich mit deinem Rechner auf meinem Rechner ein und ich greife dein Passwort ab und du meldest dich nicht direkt bei Facebook an.
Also die Frage, die ich, ich wollte jetzt nicht auf einen konkreten Facebook Hack raus, sondern die Frage, die ich mir gerade stelle, ist, wenn ich jetzt jemand bin, der einen Laptop hat. Ich benutze ihn zu Hause und ich benutze ihn auch in einem Café und überall wo ich damit hingehe und überlege mir jetzt, ob das gefährlich ist, wenn ich meinen WLAN aufmache. Dann ist es doch sozusagen eigentlich diese Sicherheit, die mit meinem WLAN, dass ich nur ganz alleine benutze, das ist doch eher sozusagen eine gefühlte Sicherheit. Aber eigentlich begebe ich mich ja eh in gefahrenen Situationen, dadurch, dass ich im Café auch meinen Rechner aufklappe.
Ich glaube, ein Großteil der Angriffe auf deinem Rechner passieren einfach nicht außerhalb deines Lans, weil ein Großteil der Angriffe, die man mit seinem Rechner ausgesetzt ist, sind so Schrottflirndenangriffe von Leuten, die einfach nur auf Rechnern möglichst viel Schadsoftware installieren wollen, um dann Spam zu verschicken, um dort deine Bankdaten abzugreifen. Und die Probleme hast du normalerweise nicht, dass jetzt irgendein Hacker digitiert, der dir hinterher ist, um gerade in deinem Netzwerk rumzuschnüffeln.
Theoretisch könntest du mehr Schaden verursachen, aber es ist einfach nicht der Fall, dass sich jemand in ein Café setzt, um dann da vielleicht irgendwie fünf Rechner, die da rumstehen, zu ownen. Sondern als kann man halt irgendwie über ein Botnet zehnmal effektiver übers gesamte Internet machen. Und dazu muss ich mir nicht die Mühe machen, um sozusagen mein Haus zu verlassen und mich in ein Café in die Sonne zu setzen.
Also ich lerne in diesem Falle zu sagen, technisch gesehen, ich soll meinen Rechner immer sozusagen so sicher machen, wie es geht. Dann ist es auch egal, ob mein Netzwerk zu Hause offen ist oder nicht. Aber ich bin trotzdem ein bisschen unbefriedigt, weil dieses Störerhaftungsding, also generell kriegen wir das heute anscheinend nicht geklärt. Also ist denn eure Meinung, wir sollten alle unser Netzwerk aufmachen und lassen uns mal drauf ankommen?
Oder?
Ja, ich weiß ja, ich bin sozusagen wirklich so ein bisschen unsicher. Was ist denn jetzt ein guter Weg?
Was ein guter Weg ist für jeden Einzelnen, muss man natürlich schauen, wo die Komfortzone des einzelnen Benutzers ist. Ich will da niemanden oktruieren, was er tun soll. Ich sag einfach nur, wie ich mich fühle. Und wenn es andere Leute gibt, die mich dann eher als potenzielle Schadensquelle betrachten, weil ich dieses Internet benutze oder weil ich da drinnen Leuten, ohne deren Personalausweis vorher aufzunehmen, Zugang zu dem Internet gebe, dann muss ich mich dann im Zweifel da mit auseinandersetzen, wenn es mich dann irgendwann mal betrifft. Aber bis dahin gebe ich einfach mal Vorschuss Vertrauen an meine Mitbenutzer meines WLANs.
Wie machst du das zu Hause? Ist dein WLAN tatsächlich einfach offen?
Mein WLAN ist offen und ich habe einen Mac-Adressenfilter, sodass alle Mac-Adressen, die ich kenne, bekommen ungedrosseltes Internet und alle, die ich nicht kenne, bekommen so ISDN-Geschwindigkeit. Unbequem, ihre Mails runterzuladen und vielleicht mal News zu klicken, aber Filesharing schnarcht einfach lohnt nicht.
Okay, also das heißt also, ich lock mich bei, also wenn ich sehe ein WLAN lock mich ein, also ist einfach nicht schnell. Dann fragen wir jetzt einfach mal die Reihe durch.
Oh, ich wohne da wo, also ich brauche meinen WLAN nicht aufzumachen. Also es wurde nicht funktionieren. Ich hab da niemanden, der, also ich wohne in so einem, ich würde es ja gar nicht im Radio sagen.
Im Wald?
Ja, so ungefähr. So ungefähr. Also ich habe niemanden, der mitbenutzt.
Aber müsstest du denn nicht trotzdem mit gutem Beispiel und wegen des Prinzips?
Nee, ich mache das auf der anderen Ebene. Ich unterstütze Leute dabei, gegen diese Abmahnindustrie vorzugehen, juristisch. Und das ist auch das, was ich halt jedem ans Herz lege. Ja, genau. Also das, sicherlich gibt es Lösungen auf der technischen Seite. Also eigentlich müssten diese ganzen Verwerter das Geld von den Abmahnanwälten wegziehen und mal in die Innovation stecken.
Hör mal auf, bitte.
Aber wir können sie vielleicht auch zwingen dazu.
Okay, jetzt hast du gerade gesagt, du hilfst anderen Leuten. Gibt es tatsächlich zu sagen, außer zu meinem eigenen Anwalt zu gehen, meinst du, das ist politische Arbeit oder auch in konkreten Fällen?
Konkrete Fälle und zwar die Freifunkfälle.
Okay, also du sagst, für die Freifunker, wenn da was passiert, bist du sozusagen als unterstützende juristische Kraft dabei?
Genau, die trauen sich nicht so wirklich zu klagen, weil man möchte ja immer so das ärmste Würstchen vom Ende fertig machen. Also bei Freifunk ist halt schon eine größere Community. Aber wenn sie dann da klagen, dann also auch in dem Vorbereich bin ich dabei und unterstütze. Also wir wollen natürlich auch, dass sie klagen.
Dann zeigen wir es euch. Verstehe, verstehe. Kai, wie machst du das zu Hause?
Ich habe ein offenes WLAN, was aber richtig offen ist. Sprich, die Leute, die sich da anmelden, kriegen auch eine eindeutige IP-Adresse. Aber mit Loggen tue ich da jetzt nichts. Also es ist eigentlich vollkommen anonym mit maximalem Komfort.
Hast du einen Plan B oder C? Also wie würdest du jetzt reagieren, wenn jetzt so eine Abmahnung mal bei dir reinflattert?
Muss erst mal eine ankommen und dann mal schauen. Beziehungsweise einfach mal rumfragen, was dann die tagesaktuelle Strategie ist. Logieren oder bezahlen oder Anwalt darauf hetzen.
Gibt es ja, apropos tagesaktuelle Strategie, wo wendet man sich denn hin?
Gute Frage.
Na, Internet. Meistens sind es ja Serienbriefe, wo man ganz sicher nicht der Einzige ist, der es bekommen hat. Dann gibt man einfach die ersten paar Worte aus dem Schreiben in Google ein und dann hat man da so eine Liste von Hunderten von Links, wo Foren voll sind von was funktioniert und was nicht.
Also ja, aber ich hätte gehofft, es gibt sozusagen so eine Art Anlaufstellen von Leuten, die sich mit so einem Thema beschäftigen. Nein.
Sollte man mal, wa?
Sollte man mal, könnte mal einer. Also es gibt übrigens den Blog zum Chaosradio und da gibt es auch einen Eintrag zu jeder Sendung. Und wenn ihr jetzt also denkt, ja natürlich gibt es das, das kann man noch direkt mal da in die Kommentare schreiben, wären wir sehr verbunden, glaube ich. So, dann kommen wir jetzt an dieser Stelle zur Werbung, weil ich glaube das Thema haben wir jetzt erschöpfend nicht gelöst, möchte ich sagen. Also wenn ihr da wirklich noch Meinung habt, schreibt auch die gerne in den Kommentaren. Podcasts, diese Sendung gibt es wie gesagt noch. Ein spannendes Thema, das uns wahrscheinlich noch einige Weile erhalten bleibt. Ich möchte den Werbeblog anfangen mit den Freifunkern tatsächlich, also weil du ja gesagt hast, du unterstützt da auch und kommunizierst dich genau mit dem Zusammensetz. Wenn man da jetzt denkt, so Freifunk gehört sich irgendwie cool an, kann man da mitmachen. Wenn ja, wo geht man hin? Was muss man machen? Und überhaupt? Bia ist gerade ganz erschreckt, aber Bia ist doch von den Freifunkern.
Ja, das ist wichtig, das ist wichtig. Habe ich das missverstanden? Nein, ich dachte du spielst da tatsächlich irgendwas ein, okay. Okay, ich bin Radiohörer, ja. Freifunk, im, die Internet der Seite, ja. Freifunk.de Punkt nett. Punkt nett, dankeschön. Und da könnt ihr die, kommt ihr an die Software ran, da kommt ihr an sämtliche Information ran, auch so, du gibt es auch einen Blog mit Störerhaftung, und da kriegt ihr die ganzen Informationen, halt auch die technischen Informationen, wie das funktioniert. Und ja, macht mit.
Jetzt gibt's ja Leute, die denken so, ja, ne bitte nicht die langen Texte, da komm ich nicht mit, klar. Gibt es so einen Tag, der regelmäßig stattfindet? Die Seabase, die ist an der Janowitzbrücke.
Richtig, genau.
Hat auch eine Webseite, kann man nach, wo die genau ist.
Die Regie teilt mir gerade mit, dass es im Internet noch eine Webseite namens störerhaftung.net gibt, Störer mit OE, bei der Dokumente und Hinweise, wenn man dort Betroffener ist, sich durchlesen kann, die auch nicht so lang sind, die Texte.
Sehr gut. So, der Club hat dann irgendwie in der nächsten Woche noch etwas vor, was überhaupt gar nichts mit Störerhaftung zu tun hat, aber auch mit dem Club und die Leute und Themen kennenlernen. Was genau passiert da?
Na, der Chaos Computer Club hat ja eine unregelmäßige und jetzt hoffentlich demnächst regelmäßigere Vortragsreihe zu dem offenen Donnerstag und zu dem nächsten offenen Donnerstag in der Marienstraße 11 in 10117 Berlin. Findet einen Datengarten statt von Constanze Kurz zu elektronischen Wahlverfahren, zu der Geschichte, zu den aktuellen Entwicklungen und zu dem Versuch mit hässlichen elektronischen Wahlmaschinen unsere Demokratie zu übernehmen und wie der CCC das verhindert hat.
Also ich wollte gerade sagen, die großen Geschichten, also irgendwie die niederländische Wahlautomaten, die hatten wir ja möglicherweise schon mal gehört. Also ist das sagen, das ein Rerun oder gibt es da noch die kleineren Details?
Es gibt erst mal ein Wrap-up von dem, was passiert ist, aber Frau Konstanze Krootz hat ja ihre Dessertationen zu diesem Thema geschrieben und hat dort viele, viele, viele spannende, kleine, neue Anekdoten und Details, die sie doch mal gerne wieder einem größeren Publikum in komprimierter Form vermitteln möchte.
Nächsten Donnerstag also in der Marienstraße 11 beim Chaos Computer Club, könnt ihr gerne hingehen und mal was Neues lernen. Ich danke Erdgeist. Danke, das freut mich. Ich danke Bea fürs Vorbeikommen und Erklären.
Auch gerne.
Und Kai für die Anekdoten und das Erklären, wie man ein Netzwerk, ein größeres betreibt.
Und wünsche euch viel Spaß. Podcast gibt es, wie gesagt, noch heute Nacht unter den diversen Webadressen. Hendrik Schröder kommt jetzt gleich, macht den Night Flight und will nur noch zu sagen, mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich habe eine wichtige Nachricht für euch. Macht immer schön eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen. Tschüss.